people of the internet retrorecontour
here i'm just a dad who loves games and
the stories they tell and welcome back
to harry potter and the prisoner of
azkaban see i told you guys i told you
it was not going to be as long between
the next two episodes so
i know we took some time uh quite a bit
of time actually
uh and it was clear man it was clear in
the last episode we were rather rusty
very rusty i know you guys really
enjoyed the
seeing me take my time on that uh on
that box puzzle
so
hopefully i'll be a little a little
sharper
in this episode today but uh i actually
i picked right up where we left off i
loaded the game back in it actually
looks like it
set me back a little bit before where we
were at
so yeah i was gonna say i guess i have
to switch over to them now
but i think that's all i had to do was
adjust that so it drops down the rest of
the stairs there okay so now they're all
they're all joined back together i'm not
sure why ron doesn't just hermione where
are you going
hermione where
what
wait maybe this is where i'm supposed to
go
why is she going back down here
i thought we were supposed to do
something up top
but maybe i'm wrong let's just take a
look at the objective here to make sure
we're
kind of on the right page in terms of
what we need to do next uh yeah collect
the carp
carpe retractum spell book
so if if i'm totally wrong and that is
where you're supposed to go then
all this will be edited out you'll
you'll never get to see uh just how
ridiculously wrong i was but no i'm
pretty sure this is the way we're
supposed to go here
yeah this little this little gate right
here i think that's where we gotta
that's where we gotta get through uh
possibly even lift this one right here
or maybe that's gonna be maybe we have
to get through there
and then we're going to be able to head
up top
and then go ahead and do something else
that will
fix that little area right there okay
now they're finally coming all right
there
they finally decided to follow me here
all right so this is the one that
hermione pressed
to make the other stairs
so harry and ron could could now get up
so now the question is where
do we go
from here
and this is i'm pretty sure this right
here i was in this area and this is sort
of where we left off last time is i just
uh it was getting late and i could not
figure out
what exactly they wanted us to do so it
looks like there's another switch up
there
above the uh above the gate right there
so it's possible that we need to get up
there somehow
um let's see i don't know can we
wow
i was like wait a second can we climb
this rope
i don't think that's been a mechanic
that we've seen yet uh again it's been a
lot it was a quite a big break between
when we played last so it's very
possible that we did learn that at some
point and i just completely forgot but i
do not remember that at all
all right so let's see does that open
okay no
oh now harry's trapped so it opened that
gate but it slides up and so now harry
is trapped in
there a way to get me out of here
and then the rest of the stairs going up
it looks like they have not been
activated all right here's a little
chest over here see if we can get it
lined up just right
because the game is so weird in that
regard
by the way i really appreciate the
positive response you guys were really
pumped on the return of this series
and i always enjoyed doing them it just
um like i said lots of hogwarts legacy
news lots of uh
life changes new job that kind of thing
so it really kind of slowed me down but
i really do appreciate the positive
response you guys were very pumped about
the return and it was honestly one of
our best viewed let's plays um already
even now so let's put your hermione here
we've got that red cap hanging out up
there
and okay looks like we can lock on there
can i lock onto this i was trying to
lock onto this little pot right here but
doesn't look like it's going to let me
okay what's going on here repair oh
probably
oh some sort of uh gas you have to watch
out for oh no it's the uh he's he's
throwing stuff at us
all right well so what is the
how are you supposed to do this
without getting hit i guess we just have
to
it just wants us to constantly move i
don't know but yeah speaking of that
positive response i'd love to hear some
more feedback on
just sort of your general preferred
style of let's plays
when i first started doing these i kind
of asked for feedback and that was when
the channel was you know
really small i mean we were just getting
started and i asked for some feedback
and most people said this is the style
they prefer where it's just you know
very little editing
basically all i edit when i do these is
i just kind of cut out the load screens
but i watch a lot of other let's plays
online too and i feel like the majority
of them
i don't know maybe it's just the ones i
watch but i feel like the majority they
sort of um they're more fast paced they
kind of they only cover the high points
and then sort of all the in-between
stuff they cut out
oh my gosh i want to lock on no luck on
there look look come on hermione come on
look down nope she's not gonna do it
okay now she does it and then we get hit
by another stink bomb or stink pellet
whatever these things are all right
finally so there had to be a better way
to do that but
so yeah it seems like there's kind of a
couple different
styles when it comes to let's plays and
obviously let's plays are not sort of
the main portion of the channel i even
started a separate let's play channel to
kind of test that out it's just retro
back into our let's plays i've put some
of my elden ring play throughs on there
and
um ended up beating the game and i've
i'm i'm way behind on uploading of the
let's plays but
so i i kind of toyed around with that
too like maybe i have the let's plays
live on a separate channel other than
the harry potter one since it seems like
there's a pretty big audience for for
those here you guys really seem to enjoy
them but yeah i'm just just really
curious in terms of your general
feedback on let's play so feel free to
comment below and and just let me know
what you think
on sort of the the overall style
but but like i said that other style
would be
uh way more edited so i might take
an hour's worth of gameplay
and distill it down into maybe like the
the best 15 to 20 minutes
with you know the just just all the
action and so a lot of the stuff in
between
would be cut out and so then another
idea had and then i'll shut up about
this another idea i had was
maybe i put like the full let's plays
like this like like the uninterrupted i
put those on um the let's play channel
that i made
and then i put sort of that fast pace
one on here and kind of just test out
but honestly
you know
i want to do what you guys want to do
you know so the this style is easier the
style that i'm doing right now where we
just uh
a lot more informal and
not a lot of editing required on the
other end
but i feel like the other videos would
do
would do better i feel like they might
reach more people but i don't know i
could be wrong it's just um
oh my goodness
am i not doing this right i thought we
had to freeze these guys maybe i just
didn't hold it long enough
and now he's officially moved away
i thought we had to freeze them and then
blast them with flupindo a couple times
but
you know what maybe it's lumos it might
be a lumos which i don't think
does hermione know lumos
is it just ron
yeah i think it's just ron there's like
some weird things about the
yeah lumos duo okay so let's switch over
to ron here
oh come on back to ron there we go
all right you know let's go ahead and
use that potion
since it looks like his health was about
half depleted there
and then hop into the menu this man i
actually really
i think this game had a lot of good
ideas and of course i still haven't
beaten it
but there are so many little quality of
life things that would have made it so
much better if they would have been able
to i don't know maybe they had time
didn't have time to fix all the things
but i feel like there just had to be a
better way
to handle the spells in this game like
like some sort of wheel
would have been much better okay clearly
i'm not doing something right and now
hermione needs help
oh she's just completely passed out over
there
oh my goodness dude i know i've
encountered these guys before
what is happening
all right so let's just maybe maybe we
need to solve the puzzle first whatever
it is in this area
all right so these things clearly
they're gonna need to uh
start flowing water again and we're
probably gonna need to freeze them like
we've done before okay hermione's back
that's good
looks like this little thing right here
might be important
it's light
so let's see if we can depend o that
maybe change the direction of it
or maybe we just need to do lumos here
oh gotta hold it down ron
gotta hold it down
and now we're locked onto the wrong
thing
we're locked onto the complete wrong
thing
yeah the spells i mean just having to
because i like i love the fact that they
said hey we want you to use more spells
because i feel like the other games
at least the two that i've played so far
i mean they've done a little of that
but this one i feel like really they've
they've done a great job of making sure
that all the spells are are relevant and
needed
all right what am i not doing right with
this guy
okay there he goes finally
oh did his own guy actually destroy him
that's crazy
all right i guess i just wasn't holding
it long enough that's there he goes
you get him nope he's still up he's
still going
oh i think i'm supposed to wait for
hermione
maybe she hit him not the i thought the
other one
like started launching stuff at him
come on hermione
oh she can't hit him
back here you come back here
oh my gosh
all right hermione come on
oh my gosh like see like she's not smart
enough to walk around
there we go we got him anyway all right
nice
but yeah youtube gives us a lot of tools
so we can kind of see
basically retention in videos
and let's plays you know it is what it
is there there are always some of the
there they're the videos where
people's attention spans fall off and
they don't watch for very long but then
a lot of you i know they're longer
videos so
you you start and then you come back
later
but basically i feel like if if there
was a more highly edited
that
that might help improve on that a little
bit and just you know make it more like
i said i want to do what you guys want
to see
so if you'd rather say hey i'd really
love to save some time and have just
sort of an abbreviated version of this
then i think we could definitely do that
or if you're like you know what i really
love i love the whole experience i love
seeing you mess up retro every single
time
i just want all of that in
then that's fine too all right so first
we've got to get this uh i don't think
we can do anything here yet
i'll just go ahead and leave it right
here though
oh yeah we're definitely going to need
hermione so let's go ahead and let go
there
we need her to freeze yep drop down what
are you doing ronnie gonna try to catch
her or something he's just standing
there right below me
all right now we can hop up
this oh wait a second i need to
come on ron hurry before it melts there
all right so now let's see he shines
lumos on it right
it working
there we go okay
does he have to stay here
no okay good
all right so let's switch back to
hermione drop down
and head this way yeah there's a lot of
little like gameplay mechanic thing like
just like her trying to drop off the
ledge right there
like the fact that she sort of grabs on
instead of just
jumping off you know
little things like that all right
actually wait i think this one's good
because it's shining
shining to there
all right so what are we supposed to do
with that guy a statue
can we get up here
no okay
i mean it kind of looked like there's a
way
like there should be a way up there
can we jump right here or is that just
harry harry the only one with the
jumping ability
okay so we can lock on to this thing
right here
hmm maybe it's ron does it need ron with
lumos
oh it just shines there
though okay now if i switch to hermione
because it almost looks like that's a
pool of
yeah that's definitely like a pool of
water so i'm thinking if she freezes
that
then it will that's exactly
why did that not work before
okay
last time i admit there were some things
when i should have gotten a much faster
like i said i was just not
not sharp but that right there like i
literally just tried that why did it not
do anything
oh and wait now i bet we have to move it
can we push this now
yes we can
okay the question is where do we need to
push it i think the eye
that eye is over here right yeah there's
the eye
oh this is a real this is a really good
one here
okay so we're gonna have to uh
let's see now if we get it over here
though
we're definitely gonna need something to
stop it right in the middle right here
oh tricky tricky
all right so
okay two things here this
the big light on top that one clearly
needs to do
something
so there's no way that they're i mean
maybe i don't have it lined up just
right
so let's go over here with ron
okay first we're gonna need hermione to
freeze it though
let's see here
okay she already got the right spell
[Applause]
all right so then let's switch let's get
ron up here
oh no that's not gonna work either
because
uh we need ron over here
so hermione's basically just she has to
freeze
and ron has to do anything involving
lumos
all right come on come on come on
okay so we actually i think we could
keep ron over here right
okay so that shines over there
all right don't leave ron stay up there
please
oh he just jumped down i heard him
yeah i feel like that's where it where
it probably needs to go
oh yeah we can't turn it anymore so
that's okay so we know we're in exactly
the right spot for this
but by shining over there it didn't do
anything
on the right side right there
we can see it
okay let me actually i like this view
right here when i'm when i'm holding on
to this
all right so what we need to do is we're
trying to get that ice block there
in perfect alignment with the
with the eye
that's down on the ground level and i'm
trying to think of any way to do that
oh goodness in this room we don't have
any blocks like i feel like there's
nothing to work with except the
i don't know can can ron like let's try
this if ron stands
he's probably just gonna move right
it's gonna say like if we have him stand
right in here
like will he will he block it by
standing here
oh this is gonna be funny either way
wow it actually worked
it was actually that's actually what you
had to do
i keep saying that like i feel like i'm
i'm really surprised at some of the
mechanics in this game
okay hermione you gotta you gotta work
with me here
oh my gosh hermione please
please hermione
there we go nice okay
yeah i'm just i'm constantly surprised
at the mechanics of this game when
things actually work
[Music]
he had to go stand there he even gets
knocked down you know he falls over
when it hits him
okay so all i can think of is by already
it seemed like the top light beam didn't
do anything but that's because i already
had that statue over there i already had
it in the right position so that's why
it looked like it didn't do anything but
i'm pretty sure maybe when it hit that
crab or something that's what created
the ice block i don't know
but clearly we open the door
we are moving on and now we gotta
remember another mechanic if you need to
stop an ice block just have ron oh no
here we go again
just have ron stand in the way
all right come on
oh so close
there we go
hermione just totally bails i mean she
just completely
just like i'm out of here sorry ron no
you're not getting any help
no help today oh wait wait she's trying
she's trying come on hermione yes there
you go thank you
she did not totally
okay all right i guess uh i guess the
angle works i don't know
seemed like she was a little far away
and down the corner for that but hey all
right so now we're back in here
and harry is still oh there's a button
right there
i was gonna say i think harry is still
behind the gate but this should open it
up
nicely done
perfect and then it also completes the
little stairs there
all right so where is harry
okay he's still up here
do i just drop down now
make sure there's nothing else oh my
gosh i almost completely jumped off with
him right there
okay so now you guys are this way all
right perfect so these are the ones that
it just completed so we can continue
on upward we've got to be getting close
to that spell book right
i do love the length of this i think
this is pretty awesome i mean we started
this in the last
last episode of the let's plays
and we've been going a good little bit
here today and still haven't got to the
end
yeah
all right another wizard card
another annoying quality of life thing i
just wish they would have some
indication maybe i'm wrong maybe it's
there somewhere
uh
yeah it's in this one right here i
believe
i think it's wizards because i remember
quidditch being done i remember us being
at one there and i think we were at one
on vampires too we'll take a look at the
vampire yeah sir herbert varney
definitely remember us reading him all
right so we've got
merlin let's go medieval dates unknown
most famous wizard of all time sometimes
known as the prince of enchanters part
of the court of king arthur
there he is right there guys merlin
all right so
glanmore peak 1677-1761
famous slayer of the sea serpent
of cromer
and then i think we've got yep this one
here edgar stroger i believe we already
had that one
and then we've got three
oh yeah we won't unlock the last one
there until we get the fourth one right
here
so we get all four of these and then it
unlocks the big one on the far right so
we've got merlin here glenmore peaks
and then edgar stroller
so i think those are the ones that are
new but i'll double check the witches as
well morgan le fay queen maeve ignatia
wildsmith the witch who invented flu
powder oh you gotta love that in
hogwarts legacy right the fact that they
uh they i think that's such a clever
fast travel mechanism in fact that it
has her name on it
gun hilda of course more here 15 56 16
39 one-eyed humpback witch famous for
develop developing a cure for dragon pox
and beatrix blocks them all right so
we've gotten all of those oh yeah let's
go ahead and look at the picture of each
of these
yep we know that statue in hogwarts
right there beatrix there she is
ignacia wildsmith
and that's queen maeve right there and
then morgan lafaye
man it is just it looks so blurry to me
after getting used to hd for so long
i'm actually playing this somebody last
time was asking am i playing this on an
emulator uh no this one is running
straight off of the let's it's the
gamecube version but it's running off
the wii hardware and it is at 480p
that high quality 480p guys i'm just
gonna walk around this way make sure
there's not anything
okay there's this right here so that i
let i i belet i was gonna say i believe
and then i change it to bet halfway i
believe that will be the exit
on that side so this one here we
probably have to go through this door
and maybe do something as a group now oh
no maybe not okay i'm totally wrong
yeah this one is running off the wii
and it's mainly because the uh oh wait
we can do something right there what is
that
we're locking on is it rippero maybe
switch to hermione we'll try i think
she's the only one who knows rapero
but yeah this this um chamber of secrets
works very well on the dolphin emulator
which is an awesome
awesome emulator for gamecube and i
believe wii games too
uh but um most unfortunately
this game does not run well at all on it
so i was like i'll just play the hard
copy
uh but yeah it's it's uh
it looks amazing but it just does not
run well
and the uh the chamber of secrets if
you've seen my let's play that that was
running on dolphin emulator
and it is just an incredible incredible
emulator makes things look so nice
so then when i have to go to the
original native version it just it looks
so weird
but i think with goblet of fire i think
that one will run well on dolphin i
don't know we'll just have to see okay a
couple things going on here over on the
left
i just saw this kind of like little
gleam of light but it's it's completely
gone now
so then we can lock on here
did harry just leave
is he all the way down there
what in the world
we already tried that door harry doesn't
do anything
okay what spells would work on this
right here
ripero's not doing anything
looks like some sort of rope
i mean when in doubt trifle pindo right
uh i mean we'll try glacious i i don't
see anything to freeze there but
so we got flopindo we got expelliarmus
we got rapero
and then glacius
nope nothing
all right well
ron what spells do you have buddy he's
got lumos
is it a match or a
rope pretty sure it's a rope
all right well harry see what you got
airy man how does harry have
the fewest spells of the group here he's
got expelliarmus influpindo
and then we got the wigan weld
yeah i guess uh i guess we can't
access this just yet
all right so let's just kind of look at
all the possible routes that we have
here
there's this way
just trying to look up here i wonder if
we
oh i wonder if we can raise
over there can't get her to look in the
right direction over this way yeah
okay
if we can oh oh oh yeah we need those to
lift up
and i think harry is oh and he's like
position that's interesting
he's positioned right here in front of
it okay can i climb this one too let's
see
yes we can all right
okay let's just get a good look around
okay so there is that them right there
oh it looks like vines like some sort of
vine
okay
so
i wonder if there's a way
[Music]
we can raise these i don't think it's
going to help anything
oh come on harry just hop down please
oh i don't want to climb i don't want to
climb
drop okay thank you
dude how crazy would it be if you could
i mean that almost looks like that green
stuff looks like you should be able to
grab on and climb there
okay let's go to hermione
and so this is already repaired right
yeah so now
what did we do we we used flupindo on it
and it looks like it's it's completely
used up
so i guess there's not anything else we
can do with that one
all right so then we were here harry had
the issue with the gate right there all
right before we go up that ramp though
let's go over this way
okay we've already been here we pressed
that button we activated the switch
there's another rope right there
which come on no way that's what we're
supposed to grab onto right
every time i've been saying that though
that's actually what ends up working you
know
all right okay i'm gonna say no i'm
gonna say no on that
okay so that right there raise that up
it's in complete alignment now
with this level
okay so now if we go up one more
need to look for some areas with rope
ah right there right there above me
see there above
okay
can harry make that jump
that's the question because if he can
make that jump
well then he can climb up
and hopefully he can hit that to
activate the switch i'm gonna try this i
think this is the same door i've already
been trying but let's
nope nothing okay
all right harry here goes nothing
we need you to try this for us
oh wait they still didn't
why did they not follow hermione
i really wonder if the game like
is the ai just that bad like they just
wander or is it actually really
intelligent and they're trying to point
you in the right direction
i don't think so okay here we go come on
airy yes
oh my gosh okay
so now
let's see do we want to go
all right i'm just gonna climb this one
so we can get
a better view here
i think we can just go all the way down
now that area right there looks
like that may be where we're supposed to
go nope this is definitely it right here
okay that was a pretty clever one i like
that
i'm just gonna raise it all the way
all right there we go so now
oh my gosh ron why do you not follow
and now hermione puts you back here
okay there's harry up there
oh wait no okay i was thinking we
switched to hermione now but
she still can't make the jump so back to
harry we go
all right so now he's gonna slide down
this way what is going on with the
camera
whoa that was a crazy camera there for a
bit
all right so then he should be able to
walk this way
and just drop there
oh but he still cannot make that jump
okay hermione's now waiting over there
all right here that's where he needs to
go
all right let's go in and then i bet
he's going to work his way around this
is my guess
but he's going to work his way around
and activate or unlock that other door
this might be it right here actually
nope
more puzzles
more puzzles it seems
oh this is the book this is it
let's go
oh and then that's what we're gonna use
in the spot in the new little the thing
that's like a vine but like a rope we're
not really sure
carpe retract them
all right so this is going to be a hairy
spell then yeah it's about time for him
to get another spell so he's up to three
now
so let's go ahead and equip that seize
and pull charm pulls an object towards
the wand
isn't that just accio
although i guess accio is more i mean
technically akio is described as a
summoning charm
akio's definitely more known
carpe retraction i don't know that i've
ever heard that outside of this video
game context
to grab oh wait am i supposed to use it
on these guys
oh we have to hold it down maybe
what
all right i'm just gonna
keep flipping knowing these dudes until
they leave me alone
oh nope not over there
right there
that one's just standing there
he's just like i don't even want to be
involved in this
oh is he too far i can't i don't think
i'm hitting him
oh these guys have shields okay
i couldn't even tell what happened over
there
okay yeah it should definitely be accio
to pull pull off a shield
to grab hold of an object press and hold
y okay i'm holding wise did it pull it
off
i'm holding it and then i'm like tucking
back on the
control stick
maybe just wasn't close enough to me
yeah i know harry
why don't you why don't you pull the
shield from him
oh finally no i don't want to walk onto
him if he gets another shield i'm gonna
be so annoyed
he's just gonna go back and pick it up
isn't he
lock on to the dude without a shield
please
[Music]
walk on yes okay take this guy out
what is he doing
i was like this guy does not have a
shield please take him out
okay finally
there we go all right
okay now
let's see
we just dropped down or am i supposed to
stay up here
okay it almost looks like this statue
right here does he have something we can
yes he does oh dude that is awesome
that was so cool that is not at all what
i expected to happen
okay this is probably just gonna pull
the platform over right
yeah there we go
perfect
all right i kind of like that it's
pretty cool i mean that looks like dude
you look at the hogwarts legacy gameplay
trailer
that little mechanic right there is
almost exactly what they're doing in
some of the areas except they're using
accio but
interesting i wonder if they looked at
this game
i'm sure they looked at all the old
games i mean
when they were planning what all they
wanted to include
it's an interesting little throwback
right there i mean obviously it's not
the only game to
come up with something like that but
still you know the fact that they okay
wait what are we supposed to do
that space looks about the right size
for you okay that's for hermione
all right so i better have to is this
the door we have to unlock
yes okay here we go
all right finally they're intelligently
in the right spot here
oh
wait a second though can he make that
jump
can he make that jump or do i can i keep
pulling it
now see i think i need to jump over
all right here goes nothing guys
yes okay now turn back that way
and then extend
there we go
all right okay hermione
let's go they said you are the one who
can go through
all right so we got the spell book
finally we we have the carpe retractum
spell now we just need to get out of
here we need to get out of this
elaborate maze that professor flitwick
has designed to house this spell book
oh perfect
opens that up maybe this is the end this
might be it right here
let's go around here open up the door
oh my gosh there's a ton of them
what's that 369 right there okay let's
switch to harry right away
yep ron not gonna do anything bud
gotta get the shields
did hermione seriously just zap me
i think she did
harry get up oh dude this is crazy
this is crazy they're everywhere what do
you have on this guy's got like full
armor
give me that shield
okay while i like the mechanic accio
shield would have been would have been
much
much more efficient
instead of this kind of like tugging
mechanic
little tug of war we got going on here
okay buddy
no get let me buy
dude
he just turned and shook his butt in the
camera
wow
how have i not noticed that yet okay
these guys are just ruthless i think
we're gonna have to run
actually before we do that though we're
gonna have to use a
oh dude we're almost out
only have one wiggin weld for harry
hey come on drink your wig wigging well
potion harry
drink the wig and bell potion
look at him dude look at him they swing
and then they they uh yeah they just
turn right in your face
right in your face
now we gotta go back to the spell
do you love that little whispering
okay no stop it
should i just i mean ron and hermione
just totally bailed so maybe that's what
we should have done
oh no they didn't bail they got caught
and are in big trouble over here oh you
know what can i just leave like can we
just
do i have to even fight these guys
oh you do
you totally do
okay do they all have the shields okay
there's one two
okay you guys do not have the shields
okay let's take you out
so we can get rid of you
yeah yeah i know that harry this guy
that i'm shooting out does not have a
shield
okay you have a shield
yeah get occupied with them exactly what
we need to have happen
nice all right
and that's it okay good job now does the
door just miraculously unlock
yes it does
uh oh
uh oh
dude flitwick was not playing around
with this area was he
okay clearly we're gonna have to use
carpe retraction we can already see on
the shields there
my only question is do i need to wait
for it to stop
or do we just oh yeah okay there you go
stop
oh my
goodness it's its own little creature
what the heck
okay now my question is do we do we have
to destroy this little guy first
okay there we go
all right he's out nice nice nice okay
now
carpet retract him again
all right we got another one to deal
with here so we gotta wait we gotta let
him run around
hermione you
gotta dodge him
and then when he gets like he does this
little number right here
you hit him in the front
okay so this is damaging the boss too we
can see that with his uh
oh no come on lock on
[Music]
alright there you go
direct hit
all right let him do his little spin
all right now you come after me
oh no he went over there
[Music]
trying to use the dodge a little bit
more
try and keep from getting hit so much
hermione unfortunately has not figured
out the dodge it seems
all right so now this dude
ron i don't know has he just left at
this point
might be he might be behind me old man
didn't dodge on that one
oh there he is there you are ron all
right ron didn't leave me
all right he's down
okay now
i think we can just
[Music]
multi-part boss in a harry potter game
oh goodness
oh my goodness
what the heck
all right so i don't see any like
glowing oh wait carpe retract them
on something up top
oh you just pull off the head
you did it i love it
and now the enchantment is broken
okay flitwick surely that is it
surely you are done flipwick
all right i'm just gonna make sure
there's not a little uh
oh wait we can't get up there can we
just gonna say i'll make sure there's
not a chest somewhere in here
you could see there being a wizard card
hidden about
all right i guess not let's go ahead and
proceed
oh wrong door
guess that's where we came in
all right my bad my bad let's go to the
other side here
50 house points for gryffindor 50 okay
at least you stepped up the point total
that new spell might come in handy
then again we could all turn in what do
you think interesting i don't know i'm
worn out that's kind of a little we have
to get off this floor
opening up a bit of free roam
prefix doing the rounds when we
literally we just got finished with
class ron
i mean we literally just finished class
and the books i mean what the heck the
books are already attacking us
my goodness flitwick
how do you not
can we do anything with the monster book
here i want to turn in
oh nick yeah now i forgot if we want to
do any exploring at all we have to
listen to ron and hermione complain we
should really turn in harry
now there's the pop-up in the middle of
the screen if you wish to stop exploring
and move
on well
what if i what if i don't there's much
to do right now
you've got to be kidding me what if i
don't wish to stop exploring guys
hermione just literally said something
about potion like we could look for
potion ingredients that new spell might
come in handy but no you guys are
constantly you you don't want me to
explore it's crazy
man i guess it's just a sign of
different times and
the other thing could probably be that
they knew this game was going to be
played by a lot of young kids so
like a little boss fight here actually
has a health meter
and maybe they were just thinking like
we we do not want people to get lost or
to get to get stuck and then be like i
don't know what to do i don't know where
to go next
but then again their puzzles are awfully
i mean
the puzzles are pretty uh
i'm not gonna say advanced but they're
certainly not like just easy easy you
know
i did not even notice this chest there
until just then oh it was just birdie
bop beans anyway but hey a lot of beans
that's the most beans we've seen in
quite some time now see guys if you all
hadn't let me hang around for a little
bit oh dude there's another one up there
see like hermione come on
okay let's switch to hermione we need
repairo
[Music]
you know what let's switch to
[Music]
i'm trying to think of like the best
combo of spell so i don't have to
constantly keep
switching between
so let's give hermione let's give her
repairo and then instead of flupindo
let's put glacis cause they all know
flopindo
and then ron let's see ron is lumos and
expelliarmus and also flopindo
so if we give ron like keep ron on
flopindo
and then let's see what can we give
harry harry obviously carpe retract him
and give him exploramus
expel e armis so yeah now we've got
everybody's got a spell like we don't
have to worry about unless they're in in
the wrong spot you know
okay so
we need hermione for this part here
it's time to turn in no it's not so
please just be quiet
okay now let's see do we need harry is
he the only one who can jump
nice dude nice
wizard card oh no more beans
a little surprised that wasn't a wizard
card there for that one since that one
required a little more uh
a little more
of a challenge to get
okay well that's two that i completely
just did not see in this room so
let's look around a little bit more okay
clearly we can do something with this
right here too
oh my gosh
and they're sitting here saying i don't
know what else to do there's nothing
else to do oh really really that's just
not even fair ron we need your
expelliarmus buddy
wow at least you don't have to
constantly lose beans in this game
though
there we go all right took those out
okay so nothing over here on that side
of the shelf
they're anywhere else where we could
lock on
now i know sometimes they've kind of
hidden
in a chest like in between the desks
here
i'm not seeing one right now all right
let's go on out here
we're not turning in yet relax
i mean we want to look around for just a
bit just a bit
okay let's go ahead and switch to
harry i still think that is crazy that
he's the only one who uh
when you're on him the map shows up all
right is the prefect gonna get mad at me
i think we're good for now
what is this right here
a little goblet
all right
second floor charms i tell you what
let's go up to gryffindor
and what we'll do is we will
check in with the notice board
oh this one's locked right here muggle
studies
let's just try it let's see if we
wonder if aloha will work
ancient runes
and on the seventh floor we have
gryffindor tower
all right so
i believe we have found an item since
our last uh
time checking in with the board
but i could be wrong we may have we may
have already
checked it immediately after
worthless braggart
worthless braggart
all right to the notice board we go and
hermione was also talking about potion
ingredients because it doesn't look like
we can
ten house points
man i really miss getting the wizard
cards
potion file case last seen on the second
floor if found please return to this
notice board all right potion vial
second floor
hey is that dean thomas
let's see
i think it
is what up dean
alright so
boys dormitory all right second floor
potion file let's go straight and look
for that i'm not sure that there's much
to do right now oh there is hermione
there is
dude how great would it be whenever
they're whining like this if you could
just say
drop ryan and hermione off at
leave them at gryffindor tower then
harry just goes off exploring on his own
so you don't have to just sit and
constantly be bombarded
all right second floor potion vial
let's see i think we were just on the
second floor right isn't that where
charms charms classroom is
there's defense against the dark arts
right there
yep second floor is charms oh wow we
were literally we were in the right spot
okay
potion vial let's see here
could definitely be like up top
on one of these bookshelves
or
wait what are we supposed to do with
this thing oh
oh that one just jumped right there okay
let's switch to ron maybe we need some
flupindo action here
oh dude there is a uh
there's a door behind that curtain
almost maybe
get out you're not allowed in here oh
stop
are you are you serious right now
are you serious
dude it's still
i'm pretty sure it's still light outside
it's light
why are we not allowed in here
okay hermione i i think this must be a
spell we don't have yet
and i don't think we uh i don't think we
have defindo do we
[Music]
i feel like i remember that but i'm
probably thinking of chamber of secrets
ron definitely does not have it
and harry definitely does not have it
okay well
i might not be able to do anything in
here then especially with these guys
at least they don't completely make it
reload
like you have to sit through the loading
screen again oh come on run run run
there we go oh there's another one right
here
oh so now the knights are all angry and
watching everything
all right so what would be the purpose
of you guys
we can't lock onto the curtain
man maybe incendio like maybe they they
set on fire and then they oh look it's a
dragon for the little tapestry too
maybe you set them on fire and then they
start breathing fire and
burn the tapestry
oh my goodness i just want you to look
another direction and i don't want to
have to use the awful camera system
he caught me again yeah we need to get
on top of that bookshelf but the
question is how
because there is a treasure
wait what did i not just see i thought i
saw a treasure it was a different one
i thought i saw a treasure on top of the
bookshelf but maybe not
okay so we've got two doors here that we
right now cannot get past
mainly because of the we don't know what
to do with the dragon now that right
there that one keeps shaking over there
might send ron over there and just see
what happens if we
blast it with flupindo although that
guy's standing right there
it's gonna be hard
which we'll do we'll wait for him to go
back that way run in behind him
dude look at the bookshelves is that ice
coming off
i just noticed that
maybe it's meant to be dust
totally looks like ice though
okay
oh no he's gonna see me when he turns
around isn't he
okay so we're gonna do we're gonna swing
it out wide
oh
my all right let's just make a quick run
to get to the other side
hey oh dude
i didn't think he actually listened i
thought it was purely based on visuals
so maybe i do have to kind of try to
sneak by him here
okay go
come on ron you got this
all right then i'm pretty sure there's
another one over here
oh no
okay so you look that way can i get can
just go like behind you
of course not
don't move
don't move ron
oh nice
okay
it's probably a waste of time anyway oh
no there it is
yeah
let's go
return the potion vial case to the
notice board for more house points all
right so whatever's hidden behind those
other doors
is uh not something we need right now oh
i love the fact that i can just switch
to hermione on the other side of the
room just switch and then immediately go
back in the door so you don't have to
sneak by them again
all right so let's head back up and then
we'll turn that in
i wonder if it like increases your
points as you uh keep keep returning
things does it ever get to be more than
just 10 because i think
every time we've done it so far dude
that kind of looks like slughorn right
there
that portrait kind of looks like horror
slughorn
that's funny
all right right here
all right back to the common room
let's return the item here at the notice
board
another 10 house points
come on you got to give us something
more than that
all right well i think we're gonna end
it there guys thank you all so much for
watching that is a good stopping point
we'll pick you back up next time from
right here as always thank you all so
much for watching and i will talk to you
again soon